hey folks good to be here New York City
baby
you know what they say about performing
when you get nervous picture the
audience in their underwear well I'm so
comfortable in these puppies
I'm wearing my underwear wearing my
sheath everybody you know sheath is made
for a sword but let's be honest I'm
rocking more of a dagger my shaft
it doesn't get along
but uh there's a little friction you
know I think my shaft has a nut allergy
that's all your underwear is just a tiny
apartment and your your shaft and your
balls are a roommate and look we all
love our roommate but sometimes he can
be a dick
thanks a lot I'm Mark Norman you guys
have been great I'm gonna go ice down
the package have a good night get some
sheep